we're a few days away from getting even
more students back in the classroom
kirsten that's right on monday the clark
county school district will welcome back
grades sixth
ninth and twelfth in a hybrid model kate
houston went to valley high school to
get a first
hand look at what students can expect on
their first day back next week 49 high
schools will welcome back
students for some in-person instruction
i'm really excited to welcome some of
the freshmen
back to campus who have never been to
campus before
valley high school math teacher lauren
engel hasn't seen students in person
in over a year only nine kids will be
seated in her classroom at a time
with a designated seating chart based on
their cohort
a will get kind of a red band and in
court you will get a blue band
principal ramona esparza is providing
students with color-coded armbands
and requiring teachers to display
attendance in the classroom
so that we know exactly which student
was there that day just in case an
incident were to happen
a test positive then we can go back and
contract traits
foot operated hand sanitizing stations
will be placed around the school
some doors have been modified with these
levers which require individuals to use
their forearm to open it
students and staff will only have two
ways to get into the school to cut
back on contact we want learning to be
fun
and it's been just such a different year
for everybody
so we want to say to them it's safe to
come back
we're here for you we are ready to
receive you and we're going to finish
this year strong ccsd has not made
modifications to the current reopening
plans
when asked about the cdc now allowing
students to sit three feet apart instead
of six feet
they said that could depend on classroom
size depending on how many students are
coming back for a particular class
and the size of the classroom but we
will space as much as we can
kate houston 8 news now ccsd is also
working on end of year activities each
school will lay out its own
graduation plan when it comes to prom
the district says it will depend on
current safety guidelines but
they'll give some updates ahead of time